what's up guys like Conan said my name
is Nick Nomura and like most people my
age I am 28 thank you thank you so so
much I really needed some laughter right
now I I just flew in and I actually got
some pretty devastating news from the
hospital I found out that my my dad has
been pronounced dead and you know it
just sort of made me think he spent his
whole life working and raising me and my
brother and my my baby sister and you
know I just can't believe that we've
been pronouncing it wrong this whole
time
thank you so much thank you so so much I
really actually I needed that laughter
because the truth is I actually got some
pretty devastating news from a different
Hospital
I found out this might be my last stand
upset for a while
because I have to get brain surgery it's
uh it's just cosmetic
Hey I feel pretty self-conscious about
all the wrinkles
so I'm just gonna have them remove the
part of my brain that feels that way I
I'm just realizing right now I actually
forgot my opening - hey everybody how's
it going my name's Emma ROPS great to be
here come you guys for coming out on
Tuesday night give yourselves round
applause for being such good audience oh
come on I know you can do better than
that let's try again one two three D
versus round applause for being such a
good audience and you guys said it and
you just needed some encouragement have
an have a hand for a terrific emcee
Conan O'Brien hey Conan how's it going
hey great glad to hear it so do we have
anybody after that now
oh you stay where you from oh hi so
where to go for fun on the second Trader
Joe's closes hey guys I'm just going
around Jake oh this guy is like whoa man
too far I got this guy in the back is
like what there are two trader doesn't
know hi hi guys I'm just gonna round
it's been a great sport everybody give
it up for Danielle
[Applause]
so some communities before talking about
relationships and our sex and let me
tell you a ting in this modern age this
isn't for me and I know this might come
surprised you guys but yeah I'm single I
know a tonal gasp it wants like what's a
sus intimidated michael cera mother
can't get a date now look guys I'm gonna
get rejected a lot but one or two bars
today try and talk to this lady that she
just left swipe dummy bit fellas you
know I'm trying everything I'm on tinder
playing a fish OkCupid fellows I'm even
on JDate I'm not even Jayesh okay
anybody here smoke weed make some noise
if you smoke well you'd have a mess in
that question cuz you know I call people
who don't answer it liars either that or
they're like oh wait what was the
question how oh man I'm so high right
now guys if you're a real stoner you
don't even do 420 it's not like 445 haha
wait so sick though so Halloween is
right around the corner here's the thing
I hate about Halloween knows all that I
could fit on my hand
I'm gonna be honest with you guys that
didn't really feel natural also there
was nothing written on my hand
[Applause]
you